Thế bằng bị cún vào vòng suốt đột khu vực sau khi mà hay bô là triệu bố,
thăm sát tấn Thông Isrend để trả đo ở việc lãnh tự,
tối, khả ạ, ạ, lì, khả, mấy đy bị sát hại trong cuộc không biết của Mỹ và Isrend,
lực lượng phòng vị Srend thông báo sẽ điều thêm hais sư đoạn đựa vào libang giám vật lượng khác bố là.
Thưa tưởng Isrend bên giám viên tên tầm giữ một được triệu bố của được Srend đã tạo xa bố.
Hãy tiếp tục sư với trong libang khi mà các lực lượng bộ bình đổ lượng tiến sâu vào libang.
Isrend, tuyên bố, đang cố gắng kịp xuất khu vực kéo sài,
những sâu lý tà đi, tích đừng dối khoảng 8 km,
bối tế libang cho biết là tổng súng người thiệt mạng liên quan đến các cuộc tấn công của Isrend vào libang,
kể từ ngày 12, tẳng ba đã tăng liên hơn một nghiên gồi.
Lý tập quốc thành báo viên tư dấu chân của Isrend và hết bố là có thể đẩy libang và sư phật tương tự như giải gà ra.